so you tell me when you're ready they
call it brain computer interface
technology but this isn't about robots
it's a remarkable achievement a
paralyzed human being able to walk again
using thought control and this man gets
janoscam who damaged his spinal cord in
a cycling accident more than 10 years
ago is living proof that it works not
surprisingly he's elated within five to
ten minutes I could control my uh hips
like they were like
the brain implant picked up what I was
doing with my hip so that was like
yeah the best outcome I think for
everyone just an example I'm training 10
years to stand up with a friend
having a beer neuroscientists and
neurosurgeons in Switzerland have used a
complex mix of medical techniques and
Technology it includes artificial
intelligence predicting what the brain
wants to do then a separate AI solution
to encode signals to the spinal column
of what the desired movement should be
we do two different surgeries there is
one surgery at the level of the brain we
do two little craniotomy put electrodes
in order to record the brain signal and
another surgery at the level of the
spinal cord where we put electrodes on
the top of the spinal cord at the place
that is responsible for leg movements so
between these two there is communication
and electrical communication a digital
bridge that is then reactivated the legs
knows only too well his ability to walk
again is down to a major experiment but
he's the one in control AI is helping
him not taking over and this along with
brilliant human skill sets are making it
all happen
Andrew Simmons Al Jazeera